was it real or was it fake if you saw
Joker this is probably a question that
you are asking and in this video I will
do my best to explain the ending of
Joker if you have not seen Joker and
plan on scene at spoiler alert we are
going to be talking about the ending so
you might want to click away hey
everyone it's Warren and the ending of
Joker left us all with some questions so
let's talk about what happened quick
reminder today is the last day of the
Nintendo switch giveaway so if you'd
like to enter follow me on Twitter and
click the link in the description down
below so let's walk through what
happened at the end of Joker in this
movie we see arthur fleck slip into
madness eventually becoming the Joker he
goes through one bad event after another
then many many more like finding out
that his mother let him be abused as a
child being mocked by his favorite
television host finding out that Thomas
Wayne was his father and then finding
out that Thomas Wayne wasn't his father
he gets jumped by some kids he loses his
job he gets betrayed by somebody who he
thinks is his friend and then he gets
jumped by three guys on the subway
having a gun on him he ends up killing
the three people who were attacking him
and although this was self-defense and
awakens something inside of him from
there he goes to the woman that he has
had his eye on for a while that lives in
his building so feed Demond he grabs her
while he's in full Joker makeup and
kisses her and she seems to really like
it which is a bit odd but back to that
in a second the two of them begin dating
and she ends up comforting him in the
hospital when his mother is dying
but after finding out that his mother
was mentally ill and let him be abused
as a child resulting in him being the
way he is now with his own mental
illnesses he kills her he then goes to
Sophie's apartment but he enters a
little bit differently this time he
enters very slowly he's noticing and
touching things on the wall and then he
sits down on the couch so if he comes in
extremely shocked and says you were in
the wrong apartment
after seconds of silence she says your
name's Arthur isn't it and we find out
that Arthur Fleck dating Sophie was all
in his head he made it up he was never
actually dating Sophie
in fact she barely knew his name just
knew the fact that he lived in the same
building eventually his favorite TV host
who made fun of him Marie Franklin
invites him on the show and Arthur
decides that he is going to go on the
show and kill himself on live television
meanwhile the clown mobs that were
inspired by author Fleck murder
the three people on the bus in his clown
outfit are starting to grow and riot
more and more he goes on Murray and
instead of killing himself he kills
Murray he blamed him and society for
making him the way he is along with all
the others who are rioting in the mobs
from here he has taken into police
custody and we see him riding in the
back of a police car
Joker killing Murray completely sparked
the clown mobs to lose control and start
rioting all across the city destroying
it author looks out the window very
happy that he caused this and then they
get hit by an ambulance of course this
was driven by some members of the clown
mob they recognized author as the Joker
who went on Murray and killed him and
sparked this whole revolution they put
him on the hood of a car in which he
wakes up and they all praise him thus
fully becoming Joker meanwhile Thomas
Wayne Martha Wayne and young Bruce Wayne
are walking down an alleyway it is here
where one of the members of the clown
mob wearing a clown mask murders Thomas
and Martha Wayne thus fulfilling the
origin story of Batman now of course
this is a twist on the origin story of
Batman this makes it to where the Joker
is pretty much responsible for the
killing of Thomas and Martha Wayne
therefore adding a very different
dynamic to the relationship between
Batman and the Joker
when Bruce becomes Batman he will most
likely seek vengeance on the Joker again
adding a twist and a very different
dynamic to the relationship the next
scene is him in Arkham state hospital
talking to a therapist
Arthur is laughing thinking about
everything that just happened and she
asked him what's so funny and he says
you wouldn't get it the movie then ends
with him walking out of the room red on
his feet implying that he just killed
her and then of course the orderly
chases him around so this is one way to
look at the movie in a literal way
interpreting it as everything that
happened in the movie actually happened
but did it happen let's take a look at
all of the evidence suggesting that none
of this ever actually happened and it
was in Arthur's head the whole entire
time now it's been established from the
very beginning that Arthur suffers from
mental illness and it was also
established that he fantasizes a lot and
there are a few things that don't
necessarily make sense in the movie
things like him getting to the front
gate of Wayne Manor him sticking his
fingers inside of the little Bruce
Wayne's mouth and Bruce Wayne not doing
anything about it and then he's able to
choke Alfred Pennyworth
alfred is much bigger than arthur and if
you know Alfred's backstory you know
that he's awesome he's a former British
military officer you're telling me that
he cannot break the grip of this very
skinny person's hands then there's the
fact that he so easily breaks into the
theater and has a one-on-one with Thomas
Wayne seems like that was a little bit
too easy for him but then again the
guards were distracted and then there's
him appearing on Murray for starters why
would Murray air footage of him to
embarrass him in the first place that's
not too friendly of Murray who is a man
who tries to make everybody like him as
a talk show host but even if he did make
fun of him why then invite him on the
show and then once he's on the show and
confesses to killing three people and
confesses to having absolutely no
remorse over it but in fact feels good
about it nothing happens
he just lets him talk and acts like he
is in no danger whatsoever no guards
come no police officers come the show
continues it's not stopped they just let
this psychopath of a person who has just
murdered three people murder Murray and
some other evidence that seems to line
up with this all being in Arthur's head
is a flashback scene in the very
beginning of the movie author is talking
to the state therapist and it goes to a
scene in a white room with him wearing
all white when he's bashing his head
against a window and he's wearing all
white and the scene this looks exactly
like the scene and the ending of the
film when he's talking to a therapist in
Arkham State hospital so is this all in
Arthur's head is this what he made up
when he was laughing talking to the
therapist in Arkham State Hospital and
when she asked him what's so funny he
says you wouldn't get it because he made
the whole thing up it was some sort of a
fantasy for him to become sort of a
villainous icon and another thing is the
Joker's origin is really unknown it's a
mystery the comics kind of allude to it
but it's really unknown having a movie
about the Joker's origin and then having
that movie be made up in the head of
Arthur Fleck is a great way to keep the
origin a mystery but at the same time
the police could have caught author
flack at the end of the movie and put
him in Arkham state hospital because he
was mentally ill and everything that
happened in the movie could have
actually happened but this is really for
us to decide but let me know what you
think do you think that this was real or
do you think that he made it up in his
mind be sure to let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down
who your favorite superhero or villain
is so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
again today is the last day to enter for
your chance to win a Nintendo switch all
you have to do is follow me on Twitter
and click the link in the description
down below as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof